Aufgepasst,
meine blassen deutschen Freunde.
Hier kommt alles, was ihr
zu Selbstbräunern wissen müsst.
* Titelmelodie *
Untertitel: ARD Text im Auftrag
von Funk (2017)
Freunde der Sonne,
der Herbst ist eine traurige Zeit
für alle Freunde der Sonne.
Vor allem für die, die ihre schöne
Sommerbräune langsam verlieren.
Selbstbräunende Lotionen
versprechen Bräune auch ohne Sonne,
aber wie funktionieren die?
Sind die gut für uns?
Und was ist da gerade
der neueste Shit auf dem Markt?
Zunächst mal:
Selbstbräuner-Bräune
ist nicht dasselbe wie Sonnenbräune.
Wenn wir Zeit in der Sonne
oder unter UV-Licht verbringen,
werden in unserer Haut Pigmente
namens Melanine produziert.
Ja, Melanine hatten wir schon mal.
In diesem Video hier,
da ging es um Haarfarben.
Bei Selbstbräunern
passiert allerdings etwas anderes.
In den meisten Selbstbräunern
ist ein Molekül namens Dihydroxy-
aceton, kurz DHA, enthalten.
Anders als die Sonne reagiert DHA
nicht mit lebenden Hautzellen,
sondern nur
mit der äußersten Hautschicht,
die aus toten Hautzellen besteht,
genannt "Stratum Corneum".
Genau genommen reagieren
die DHA-Selbstbräuner-Moleküle
mit Aminosäuren
aus unseren toten Hautzellen.
Ihr werdet nicht glauben,
was für eine Reaktion das genau ist?
Die Maillard-Reaktion!
Was?
Wer meine Emotionen
nicht genau nachvollziehen kann,
hat wohl unsere Videos
zum Backen und zum Grillen verpasst.
Die Maillard-Reaktion
ist eine meiner Lieblingsreaktionen,
weil sie beim Backen und Kochen
für all die leckeren Aromastoffe
und all
die wunderbaren braunen Farben sorgt.
Also noch mal:
Ob du Plätzchen braun backst
oder Bacon braun frittierst
oder Selbstbräuner benutzt, es ist
alles dasselbe chemische Prinzip.
Heißt das jetzt,
ich backe meine Haut?
Ist Selbstbräuner überhaupt gut?
Die Reaktion zwischen DHA
und unseren toten Hautzellen
ist völlig unbedenklich
und verläuft auch bei Raumtemperatur
bzw. Hauttemperatur.
Bei den Konzentrationen, in denen
DHA in den Lotionen eingesetzt wird,
das sind so um die 5 %,
konnte man
keine schädlichen Folgen beobachten.
Es gab zwar eine Studie,
die herausgefunden hat,
dass DHA nicht so gut
von mexikanischen Nackthunden
vertragen wird. Was?
Ja, mexikanische Nackthunde.
Wer kommt auf die Idee, Selbstbräuner
auf mexikanische Nackthunde zu tun?
Wenn ihr zuhause
einen mexikanischen Nackthund habt,
schmiert ihn nicht
mit Selbstbräuner ein.
Eins sollte man allerdings bedenken,
die Moleküle,
die uns die Fake-Bräune verschaffen,
heißen Melanoidine.
Die sind übrigens auch
in Kaffee drin.
Jedenfalls sind sie nicht dasselbe
wie Melanine, unsere Hautpigmente.
Die Melanine, die im lebenden Teil
unserer Haut entstehen,
schützen uns z.B.auch
vor weiterer UV-Strahlung.
Die Melanoidine vom Selbstbräuner
allerdings kaum.
Noch schlimmer: 24 Stunden nach
dem Auftragen von Selbstbräuner
ist die Haut sogar noch empfindlicher
gegenüber UV-Licht als sonst.
Deshalb sollte man Selbstbräuner
immer in Kombination
mit Sonnenmilch verwenden.
Da Selbstbräuner-Bräune
aber nur auf der Färbung
der äußersten
toten Hautschicht beruht,
hält diese Bräune
auch nur ein bis zwei Wochen,
weil sich unsere Haut
ständig erneuert.
In Boston
arbeiten die Wissenschaftler
aber gerade an einer
neuen Selbstbräuner-Revolution,
wo die Haut auch ohne Sonne
zur Produktion von echtem Melanin
angeregt werden soll.
Das gäbe
nicht nur nachhaltigere Bräune,
sondern auch
einen extra Sonnenschutz.
Drücken wir den Wissenschaftlern
die Daumen. Schönschlau!
Was ist mit euch?
Wer von euch benutzt Selbstbräuner?
Oder habt ihr das nicht nötig?
Oder steht ihr eher
auf eine aristokratische Blässe?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare
mit euren Fragen. Bis nächste Woche.
Bis dahin - bleibt sicher.